[Music]
welcome to another episode of the addie
hour as always i've enjoyed hosting
these conversations and enjoy having
conversations with my guests on this
program but today i'm extra excited for
this this specific program a specific
topic we'll be covering and also very
excited about the guest who's joining so
today we'll be talking about sleep
emotional wellness and mental health
something which i think all of us can
relate to and i'm honored to be able to
host dr oboe addy on the podcast the
original dr addie uh in a sense so
obviously you can tell i'm excited about
this and really i'm grateful for his
willingness to jump in and to be able to
share um so many important tips with all
of us so by way of introduction dr oboe
addy is currently a sleep physician at
the university of michigan health west
he also has an appointment as a clinical
associate professor in the departments
of medicine and psychiatry at michigan
state university he's had previous
positions at places like case western
reserve university also at emory
university school of medicine in atlanta
and he's someone who has been deeply
involved in both psychiatry and sleep
medicine for over 30 years so has
expertise on both sides of the owl so to
speak and their intersection between the
two
he's a husband he's also a father of
four children and a grandfather of five
and he's someone who continues to be
invested in many different ways in the
community through his church but has
also done things in the broader
community even in his semi-retired state
right now he's been involved in setting
up sleep clinics in ghana for the past
several years and so has continued to
make sure
that the expertise that he has and what
he's been able to bring to the community
and to different fields of medicine
continues to have impact in lives so i'm
grateful to be able to welcome him today
just as a
little bit of a full circle i remember
growing up and watching him on a cnn
interview where he was talking about his
work and being very proud and all
inspired so it's full circle for me to
be able to host him on my own podcast
and grateful to welcome dr oboe addy to
the podcast today
thank you thank you very
much thanks for being here and i'm just
excited to be able to
move this conversation in a lot of ways
and this has been something that's been
in the back of my mind for a while just
the benefits that i've had growing up
with you and all the insights that
you've shared with us over the years so
as you
as you wear the phones i'm reminded of
the picture you took when you
agreed to be
a guinea pig for the all the electrodes
i put on your head and things for a
sleep recording as i was testing a new
machine
that's true maybe that's what piqued my
interest initially even though i think
at the time i was trying to revolt in my
mind and go far away from your field
which i was very unsuccessful at
at some point we have to find that
picture if you have it yes yes i know i
have it someplace i'll look for it
excellent
well as my listeners know um i always
like to just check in and see how my
guests are doing overall so just with
all the different things that you're
doing in your semi-retirement with your
family responsibilities even the ways
that you've helped my family out in the
last few weeks and the sleep clinic that
you're doing in ghana how is everything
in your own life especially in the midst
of the ongoing pandemic
well kovid affects everything it did
affect the planned trips to ghana
but on a personal level one of the
things i found a little disruptive was
the most recent trip to ghana actually
last two
one in april and another in july and
what you have to go through with kobe
testing that within a two three week
period i had to have have three covet
tests which are not pleasant so then
there's one test 72 hours before the
flight and then when you get to ghana
you have a rapid test at the airport and
you stay there for the results before
you can leave the airport and then when
you are coming back you have to have
another covered test so for me
having three covey tests
in a two three week period was not very
pleasant
but to put it in perspective i mean i
had the understanding the reason for
this is for my own health and for the
health of others and i think a lot of
people are going through this where
there is some
discomfort or annoyance about some of
the things that we have to go through
but i think we have to be open to
accepting these inconveniences for the
overall good so
that's that's my personal experience
with kovid and how to deal with it no
that makes a lot of sense and it sounds
like these weren't the um
the the the painless test it sounds like
i mean you had the deeper slobs and all
that as well and
yes and the very first one that i had i
said it's like somebody's trying to poke
a needle into the base of your employees
wow that that is saying something for
you as a psychiatrist to use that
that analogy as well but i think you
said it well too in terms of just people
being willing to have the inconveniences
for their own health and for those
around them as well how are things not
to jump too far ahead but how are things
in ghana when you went as well in terms
of people's perspectives about prove it
and a willingness to kind of abide by
some of these practices and things like
that
people have been
fairly accepting i mean you
they are no
very protests and that there are people
who are uncomfortable but as opposed to
maybe things we see in the western part
of the world people are more accepting
of what the government's position on
things is
i think it's it's because of the maybe
the traditional way of
things and the way things are set up
that people look at more to authority in
a lot of ways or to the elders so the
president in that sense is the
most senior elder for the country so he
says this is good for us although people
may not like it they are generally
accepting and people are wearing their
masks i mean there are people who are
not following the rules but but by and
large people are accepting and
recognizing that there is a problem
going on it's a pandemic and people want
to see it controlled
oh that's encouraging to hear and it
seems like with that role with the
elders too there's the um there's two
sides that because there's the urn
there's the respect that's there but
then it seems like it also has to be
kept as well and not
used in a way that
actually is harmful to people so there's
a lot of
weight there as well in some ways and
maybe that's what has led to some of the
detector shifts in
the african continent that because of
their respect for elders yeah some of
these leaders have abused that privilege
and and we've seen dictators there
unfortunately yeah that makes a lot of
sense and it's encouraging to hear that
things are in that
moving in that way now at least i'm gone
in a lot of ways
it actually
leads to next question just thinking
about your profession
um as someone in sleep medicine as well
because i know obviously personally from
your
your trajectory and your past going into
psychiatry there were aspects that came
up initially in terms of whether that
was whether that was um favored by the
government the types of work you're
doing and how it was looked upon and how
that shaped your own past so i think it
would be helpful for a lesson if you
could share how you got into psychiatry
and sleep medicine in the first place
and i guess the intersection between
your personal story and the role of the
government as much as you're willing to
share yeah i think god gives us
different interests and affinities for
certain things so
i don't know that i can pinpoint
what led to my interest in psychiatry
but there was a very early interest in
the things of the mind and how that
works and i think that also relates to
my christian faith and background as to
what god is doing and it's not just all
the things you can measure that much so
there was an initial interest in
psychiatry but in medical school in
ghana that was downplayed the idea was
we have big problems with infectious
diseases and other things and why would
anyone want to focus on psychiatry that
is
not that important so
for me the whole thing came more to
light when i was doing my rural service
in ghana
and as a general medical practitioner
you are doing everything that
one year or two years out of medical
school doing everything means i was
doing things like hernia surgeries and
one of the most satisfying was doing
emergency cesarean sections
and to have a
healthy mother and a healthy baby
afterwards
but then what struck me as i was running
a clinic that was that there were people
who were coming in especially some of
the women from
maybe abusive families who patiently
would be at the clinic seeking some care
and
there was no physical
code
or need at that point it quickly became
obvious to me that these people had
emotional problems that nobody was
dealing with and they were coming to the
clinic and coming to the doctor for help
but then the thing that maybe promoted
more the interest to pursue my interest
in psychiatry was this i knew how to
handle most medical emergencies
i knew how to treat routine things like
the malaria like i said i could handle
the emergency had near office i could
handle emergency cesarean sections i had
no idea how to handle any psychiatric
emergencies
so it struck me that there was this
clear need there and although this had
been downplayed what my professors were
saying was not really accurate that
there was no need there was a huge need
so then that
led me to follow the interest and the
affinity that i say god had given me to
go into a field that would help those
who are emotionally distressed and
needed help
yeah that's encouraging to hear and how
so how did you take those steps if the
avenue wasn't clear in a sense if the
president wasn't there also
yeah so then i did talk to
well he wasn't actually an uncle by
marriage who was a psychiatrist who i
looked up to so i asked him how one
would do this so
it did encourage me but then he said
well you may have a glorified idea of
what psychiatry is so why don't you get
a clear idea so he invited me to
work with him for some time attached to
the main psychiatric hospital
in the capital in accra
and
this was the old type asylum
like i mean there were
good rooms but then some of them were
basically being
put there just for custodial care and
that wasn't much good treatment
in a sense he opened my eyes to see
maybe the worst part of it
but instead of well he said if you want
to go into this you want to see the true
picture but that heightened my interest
rather than dumping it and i felt like
well this is something that i was
willing to do
so he did encourage me along the way but
there was no avenue for going to
psychiatry and to
make things a little bit more
interesting
the head of surgery had developed an
interest in me and i suppose i was good
with my hands with surgical interest so
he invited me to go into surgery and i
was going to have full sponsorship to do
that
and there was no avenue for going to
psychiatry
and yet i felt like this is what god was
calling me to do
so when the chief of surgery asked me
invited me to come into surgery i was
forced to make a decision then i did
write to him to say no i'm not going to
surgery i want to go into psychiatry
and he reacted like why would anyone
choose to go to psychiatry especially
since there was no clear path for me to
get there and it was a clear easy path
for me to become a surgeon
but yeah i did talk to my uncle and then
they said whole long story but then the
steps fell into place and i did end up
going to psychiatric training at duke
where the young man who is interviewing
me
yeah that's another whole long story
full circle in many ways so it's always
i mean i always feel like i learn more
each time i hear the story so it's also
encouraging to hear your willingness to
follow the passion even though others
weren't necessarily
supportive in that sense and then how
did the sleep part become integrated
into this story
yes it's in a sense as i was thinking
about this
it's the same kind of a story
in terms of the human interest the need
to help others like i said i was in this
royal medicine and these ladies were
coming in and they had
psychiatric needs that nobody was
dealing with that nobody knew what to do
about
it was in my first year of trading
at duke
that a patient come in came in and i
labeled him the lazy farmer so
so this guy belonged to a farming family
and
he was always sleepy and tired and he
would go to the tractor and his brothers
who see him out in the middle of the
field
sleeping on the tractor and they said he
was lazy i mean he didn't like to work
like his brothers
then somebody thought well maybe he has
some medical problems maybe it was a
seizure problem or some other thing so
he was brought to duke for a full
workout and it was in the workup that my
professor then the person was training
me
in eeg i was in the psychiatric program
but i was doing the
eeg training which was combined with it
and he said maybe this guy has
sleep apnea
maybe he's not lazy after all and that
was the first i heard of anything like
sleep apnea well to not make it a long
story he he did have a workup they were
not established sleep clinics then
but he had workout size when he had
treatment but that thing stuck in my
mind
this guy had a genuine medical sleep
problem
he was labeled by family and friends as
lazy
so the thought was how many other
so-called lazy farmers are there who
need help
who nobody is giving the help to
so that's what i'm saying maybe in a
sense as i was looking at this
we have our own way of processing things
so there's a rural
people psychiatric patients in ghana
nobody was taken care of how many are
there that needed help then there's a
lazy farmer how many more are there
how many more lazy farmers are there who
need help so again the interest was
going to this thing if you can to try
and help people with that
but it didn't mean that i went directly
into that i mean i had the interest
there
but there was no avenue to follow it
again this looks like the same story
before
it was years after i had left duke that
i was working elsewhere where an old
professor from duke came to give grand
rounds
and he says we want to develop a sleep
program i mean he was at everything
and i know your background that you were
combining psychiatry and
eeg things and i think you'll be an
ideal person to help us
get a program going so it was an
invitation and then
so i didn't realize that this interest
was known to any others but obviously
sort of become
known to others so then i did pick up
where i had left off so to speak and
that's how i came into sleep it's a long
way to say it but i hope that
that's good and it seems like some of
the the passion was there but you didn't
necessarily have the opportunity
initially and then it still came from an
invitation later on that you're able to
take advantage of
which seems really important it's also
interesting hearing the story because it
in the sleep side seems to parallel a
lot of what's happened with mental
health in this country and globally as
people have had better awareness and
trying not to label people as just you
know
the aunt or uncle who's a little bit off
or this and that but with the same thing
with sleep because the farmer was just
being labeled as lazy without a true
awareness
of the do you think that's moved over
the years or are people still are there
still things people are unaware of in
terms of
sleep and how sleep problems can affect
our daily lives i think it's improved a
lot i mean a lot from
yeah even when i started i was yeah the
early phases about 30 years ago but when
we moved to grand rapids the clinic
maybe about 20 years ago and one of my
colleagues there were three of us that
started my basic training in
psychiatry there was a neurologist and
then a pulmonologist
and it's the pulmonologist who had the
hardest time 20 years ago a lot of his
colleagues were making statement i mean
you went to medical school and you spent
time specializing in
and now you want to do sleep medicine
it's like you're giving up all your
medical training what is sleep medicine
why would you want to do that so there's
a huge move from that so i think there's
greater understanding even compared to
20 years ago so it's good to see that
yeah that's really important what do you
think um what do you think about the
understanding because we talked about
from the medical perspective what about
in the general public do people have
more of an awareness or do is there
still this
lazy farmer
attitude that happens when people are
struggling with with disturbed sleep
yeah i think in the general public
there's a greater awareness of this and
greater understanding
you still hear because recently as maybe
two or three years ago i've had a parent
call
a child with narcolepsy lazy and became
a conflictual situation where mother was
a more exception that there was a need
and our father would think of no he's
lazy he's not like his brothers if he
were he would
do such and such yeah but again it's
it's moved so there is general awareness
as has improved but i still need to move
forward this past week i read something
that
the nih has given
is giving a three-year grant to the
economy of sleep medicine to work on
increasing the awareness
so there's a recognition there's a need
to do more public education
yeah
on
this
seems important just in terms of every
aspect of our
of our lives is how important sleep is
um so i'm also curious just you know for
our listeners as well what are some of
the
things that you usually tell people when
people are trying to understand what
what is because i've heard you use the
term sleep hygiene before what does good
sleep hygiene look like and also
how do people know if it's a sleep
disturbance that they're dealing with or
if it's something else and how do they
know when to get help
yes sleep hygiene refers to things that
you can do to promote your sleep but
there is
maybe to
back up on what are the important
components of sleep okay there is
sometimes people who say what is the
quality of my sleep if i sleep well i
have good quality sleep
then if it doesn't matter if it's three
hours or four hours but there are
things that we know about sleep sleep
duration is extremely important so and
we can talk about this later
as well
that sleep duration alone regardless of
quality if it's not adequate duration
can lead to major health problems so one
of the things that we
need to know about sleep is that we need
to get enough of it
and we can
cheat with it it has consequences if we
do not get enough
and then the other component is
sleep continuity it's preferable to get
all of our sleep
in one block
as much as possible when i've talked to
medical groups well especially when i
was in ghana the last time and then
young physicians will say well i'm on
call some of the time but what if i get
two hours of sleep
now and then i'm awake for the next four
hours and get another two hours and then
i get an hour and a half
someplace
even if you have the same total duration
if you get eight hours of sleep but it's
broken up into three or four pieces with
one or two hour intervals as opposed to
seven hours i'll use that's an example
seven hours of continuous sleep
seven hours of more continuous sleep
is more refreshing and has better health
consequences than a total of eight hours
of sleep broken up into five or six
segments so the duration is important
and getting consecutive hours of sleep
is important
when you ask about sleep hygiene that
this refers to the poor habits that can
make your
sleep quality
less than adequate
so things like
reading in bed especially if you are
reading on an electronic device it may
be a low light intensity but that kind
of thing can still affect your sleep you
can delay sleep onset
things like
stimulants or even drinking coffee and
drinking coffee in the evening can
affect you so those are the things you
want to
guide against
keeping a regular sleep weak passion is
important
and again if it's irregular it will be
more harmful than good but there is a
component that most people don't
recognize which i think is important
some people say go to bed at the same
time and get up at the same time but the
important thing is to fix your wake-up
time
the bedtime in a sense will take care of
yourself or the sleep on set
it's easy to remember this if you look
at it this way you can make yourself
wake up
but you cannot make yourself fall asleep
but what people sometimes do especially
if they're having some difficulty with
their sleep
onset we'll say if i get into bed at 10
then i'll 10 regularly then i'll fall
asleep by 11 or something like that
but if you have problems falling asleep
and you get into bed when you are not
sleepy your level of anxiety can
increase and the longer you're in bed
the longer you get
the more anxious you get and the more
difficult it becomes to sleep
so fix your wake-up time
and try not to sleep too much during the
day we can talk about that later too and
then when it comes to night time your
body will take care of that time so
avoid stimulants at night maintaining
good regular rhythm for other things
even including your meals
good regular exercise
good health and avoiding long periods of
sleep during the day these are some of
the components of sleep hygiene sleep
hygiene itself would not cure a
significant sleep problem
but maintaining those habits can be
helpful now those are all really really
good uh tips do you ever get
um pushback from people because i can
imagine people say oh but i have this
and this and this to do or this job
situation or this circumstance and
that's not feasible so what do i do if i
can't get all of those things in place
well if i can't get a consistent wake-up
time or
or you know family responsibilities or
infants at night that's a whole another
topic but how do you help people in
those situations yeah i think it's one
can use a same approach you use for
anything else
and that yeah somebody has diabetes so
they have to work their diets and things
but every so often a circumstance comes
up where they cannot follow that yeah so
you can
break from that on a short-term basis
but not on a long-term consistent basis
yeah so you are going through this
somebody has a baby baby is waking up at
night well there's you need to be up to
help your baby so there's not a whole
lot you can do about that but as soon as
possible you want to get back to the
good ongoing consistent practices these
are all things that you want to be doing
on a long term ongoing basis and it's
important to keep those in mind
no but when it comes to sleep hygiene
even people who have significant
difficulties
usually as soon as you
begin to mention it a lot of patients
will say no i've done all of that and it
doesn't work
but
almost always when you delve into it you
can see that there's a significant
component they are not following
one big component is a daytime nap okay
i often say there's a good way to take a
nap and a not so good way to take a nap
a good nap is one that is more in the
middle of the day because it's a natural
dip in the middle of the day
a good nap is one that is generally no
more than an hour long
and
it's maybe a half hour to an hour will
be sufficient but what some people do
who have significant problems is they
are following these things but then they
don't get a good night and then
they more or less crash as they put in
and then they will sleep for four hours
one afternoon
just to make but that throws things off
so they think again go back to a regular
rhythm and follow the good luck
guidelines for a nap don't
go for days without adequate sleep and
then sleep for four or five five hours
during the day on some some some day
that's really helpful assistance is
important yeah and it's the way you're
sharing the stories it seems like a lot
of times people are
just using their own best educated
guests to try and address things but
that might not necessarily be what's
best for the situation exactly exactly
so that's helpful to hear i'm sure
people are i imagine people are taking
notes or even thinking about ways to
apply these pieces as well
i was also just going to ask about
insomnia just because anecdotally just
talking to people there are so many
people that say they have problems
falling asleep at certain times of their
lives and how are those rates changing
over time or are people just more aware
of those sleep disturbances yeah i would
say people are more aware because it's
that the studies showed
that about 10 of people have significant
insomnia and this is longstanding 10
percent is is the big number that has
been more or less stable and then
when we talk about insomnia many would
tend to focus on the difficulty falling
asleep in the first place
by definition that's not all there is
some may fall asleep
easily
but have difficulty maintaining sleep so
the difficulty maintaining sleep is also
a problem
or
there are those that wake up too early
and that is insomnia too
it's important in the definition though
to
add
the third component
it's not just difficulty falling off to
sleep or maintaining sleep but it's
associated with some impairment in
daytime functioning
that is important because it's a it's a
lady during my training in sleep
medicine this lady came in and she was
quite distressed because she had
insomnia
so then we asked the question so do you
have difficulty falling off to sleep she
says no
do you have difficulty staying asleep
she says no and when you wake up in the
morning do you feel refreshed she says
yes
but i'm getting about six and a half
hours of sleep six to seven hours but
everybody in my family sleeps about
eight to
nine hours so i'm insomnia because i
have a few hours of sleep
but the hours is not everything so
insomnia means
you
have difficulty falling asleep or
maintaining sleep and you also have some
daytime consequences to consequence to
it
so
if you are sleeping fewer hours than the
rest of your family but you feel
perfectly fine you feel perfectly
refreshed then by definition you do not
have insomnia so i think it's important
it's not the number it's just the things
that go with it
and i think maybe i
deviated from what your question was but
that yeah that's helpful as folks i know
just talking with people people from
different families have said oh you know
well some people in my family sleep four
or five hours and they went in for all
the sleep studies to see is there
something but they said they've been
functioning fine and so eventually they
were just told that that was how they
operate but then you know they interact
with others and people think oh what's
wrong with you why are you only sleeping
four hours a night that can't be healthy
so what you share is definitely helpful
for that perspective as well
yes but it's also important to add that
there are some who claim that all they
need is four or five hours of sleep
the thing is that
we say the general rule is most people
the academy stands by this seven to
nine hours of sleep is adequate sleep
all the studies show that when your
model is consistently getting less than
six hours of sleep there can be major
consequences
and this includes consequences like
daytime sleepiness or tiredness there
can be cognitive impairment you are not
as sharp as you
should be and sometimes people do not
recognize it and sometimes i'll say if
somebody is an
a student or a plus student and is
performing at a b plus level i mean it's
not
i would say that's acceptable too but if
you're an a plus person functioning at b
plus level you're actually not
functioning at your peak and you don't
recognize it so
so things like generally less than six
hours of sleep
can be an impairment your risk of
cardiovascular consequences is
higher your immunity level is high
studies have been done there's one that
struck me came out recently that's a
common cold
that
and
people who were sleeping less than six
hours of sleep i mean didn't ask them to
change anything just selected groups and
those who are getting adequate sleep
seven to nine hours
those sleeping less than six hours of
sleep generally and they are healthy
when the two groups are exposed to the
common cold virus
those who sleep less than six hours have
a full fourfold increased risk of
getting the cold i suppose those two
sleep adequately
i see that as important these disc of
coffee nobody has studied that but if
you are sleeping consistently less are
you at greater risk of getting covered
we don't know that but we know that
people have a higher risk of like i said
a heart attack they have a higher risk
of developing
other
medical consequences so we should take
insomnia seriously it does have
consequences
when i talk about mental health where i
say my background is mental health too
we know that those with long-standing
long-term insomnia have a greater risk
of developing depression or having
anxiety problems those with depression
are more likely to have insomnia but
those with insomnia are also more likely
to develop depression
and sometimes people feel like insomnia
is just my problem or
i can just deal with it on my own but
there are times that it does need to be
looked at professionally and managed so
yeah
long answers to short questions but all
very good and very helpful and i'm sure
again i'm sure that this is something
that's very that people are just
thinking about because i'm sure in
people's own lives or people they
interact with there are lots of things
they may have noticed that they've never
really heard talked about as fully um
before so it's really helpful to have
that as well and it makes me think about
what you said about the public uh
conversations and the emphasis on that
in the next three years i think that's
that's very important
as well
and how do you even i was thinking about
what you were saying about people you
know operating at lower level then they
that might not be their peak
performance how do
how do you help people realize that
because if someone has been in that
whether someone's been operating a
v-plus for 10 years and that's the norm
do you leave it that way do you help
them to try and
adjust to to improve their quality of
life or how does that conversation get
started
yeah it's difficult to convince people
when they don't see the evidence
on their own so
we talk about insomnia i'll shift to
something else out
the lazy farmer had sleep apnea so i'll
talk a little bit about sleep apnea at
this point sleep apnea is when you see
some of the most dramatic changes and
addresses this question about
functioning at the
b plus level instead of a plus level
you see somebody who comes in they have
loud snoring
they have some tiredness and sleepiness
during the day
often
this is common in men so the man comes
in not because he thinks he has a
problem but because he's tired of his
wife complaining that he's snoring
so loudly she is not getting good enough
sleep
he comes in he has a sleep study a
diagnosis of sleep apnea is made he gets
active treatment for that one of the
most common treatments is the cpap
continuous positive pressure device
that it was and
it's maybe surprising or amazing or
maybe not
but
people will come back and they said i
should have done this 10 years ago
because all this time so i thought it's
just my age that because now i'm 45 or
50 that's why i'm not i've not been as
sharp
but you treated sleep apnea and this
goes away so that's when they recognize
it's extremely difficult to convince
people they are functioning at a lower
level so they see themselves
so that the goal is not so much to
convince them that they will function at
a higher level but to say
this we know it's a problem this is a
medical condition if it's insomnia if
it's necessary
so let's treat it and see what happens
and i often offer people let's give it a
try
let's see what happens
another thought comes to mind it's
i say i love to be proven wrong in terms
of
working so a lady comes and she's
averaging about 20 cups of coffee a day
and she's saying she has insomnia and
she needs help and i said well you talk
about that sleep hygiene one of the
first things you can do is to try and
cut back down on how much coffee you are
drinking per day
and she wasn't convinced it didn't make
any difference but these were onwards
when she came back for her first
follow-up
she says i decided to do this to prove
you wrong
i was sure it wasn't going to make any
difference but i thought okay i'll i'll
just cut back i'll cut back to half my
consumption and i'll go back to this
doctor and i'll just show you how i'm
wrong ahead she comes back and she's
surprised
so this is why i said no it's it's great
to be proven wrong
on this okay i like telling sorry so
then there is
going back to sleep happiness see a 70
year old guy is about 70 and
sleep apnea can present in unusual ways
for some men of
it can cause you to go to the bathroom a
lot four five six times at night
and this was this patient's major
problem
so he goes to see a urologist and the
urologist says no your prostate is fine
in span of your age we don't need to do
anything there he comes to the sleep
clinic
and he's upset and he says my doctor is
a good doctor which is why i follow
through but i think it's wrong
what does waking up a lot to go to the
bathroom at night have to do with sleep
it's
it's my waking up that is disturbing my
sleep he should fix that then i'll be
fine but he says i should be at the
sleep clinic so i'm here
oh and the way he put it i know it's my
age
and it's my prostate
i can't do anything about my age if you
fix the prostate i'll be fine anyway he
goes through the sleep study he has
confirmed sleep apnea he gets
treated he comes back
for his first follow-up that's about six
weeks later
and he's saying
strange thing that happened he forgot
some of our discussion now i wake up
only once to go to the bathroom
so then i asked him did the urologist
decide to do your prostate
he says no
and then i asked him maybe
so i said are you still 70 years old and
he looks like me
what is he talking about i said you told
me it was your age and your prostate
your prostate is still there and you are
still stemming too
so
yeah so well it's again a long way to
answer this question that
you cannot really convince people
until after they've had the treatment so
the goal is to try somehow to get them
to agree to the treatment and often will
phrasing that
this is a test let's do it you don't
lose anything else about the worst is
you lose the co-pay for the work up and
the test and if you prove me wrong
that's fine but yeah so
yeah well it's not it's interesting
because it sounds like you're using some
of the psychological tools as well
to get people to uh
to go through it and experience it and
then and then see the outcome but it
sounds like it's so um i mean it's so
transformative in a lot of ways
but i guess the other question is
because as you're talking it seems that
also within the medical community people
have to be aware so the fact that the
urologist actually sent the patient to
the sleep clinic was also important do
you think that's something that's
uniform across the board or is there
are there disparities that come up in
terms of the access to care that people
have and whether people are cognizant of
that and i mentioned that just because
of some of the things that we talk about
in terms of you know some of this
systems in place in the us and how that
impacts different communities and
communities of color in particular and
whether there's equal access to these
services especially around sleep because
as you mentioned it has so many
impacts on so many aspects of our health
just our physical health and our mental
health yeah
yeah a couple of things it's in terms of
referrals unfortunately there are still
healthcare providers
who are not paying enough attention to
sleep issues
i mean the clinics that i've done in the
past and even in my current position
you often will see
the same kinds of
names or
certain primary physicians
have a lot of referrals coming through
and some have almost none so he said
obviously
people with sleep problems are not
pre-selecting who they would see
so that will mean that there are some
clinicians who are not paying enough
attention to send the patients
access is a huge problem actually i was
looking at something this week the
mobility and mortality weekly report
from the cdc
the one from september 24th so this yeah
this past week
it was looking at sleep in children
four months old to 17 years so children
are adolescents
and it said about a third in that group
a third are not getting
the
adequate duration of sleep that they
need and there are regional differences
it's about 25 in maine
about 49 in mississippi
and when you look at this we say we do
know that inadequate sleep has health
consequences
but you see greater risk
or higher prevalence
in
racial
and ethnic minorities and then in areas
where the economic socioeconomic
people are at the bottom or the lower
end of the economic climate
so these groups have higher prevalence
rates of almost all sleep
disturbances and they have lower rates
of access
there's another thing that makes that
even more distressing is this that when
it comes to the things like sleep apnea
if you have the same level the
consequences are often worse
racial minorities for so there are
ethnic and racial differences so if you
have for example a caucasian with
a certain degree of sleep apnea
and there's a
black person who has the same degree of
sleep apnea the chances that the black
person even with the same access will
get
more health consequences are higher so
yeah so it's not equal and the academy
of sleep medicine right now is trying to
pay attention to that to the racial
ethnic and social economic disparity in
the distribution and the
availability of access to treatment for
these groups yeah that seems very
important especially because of the way
that you phrase for all because that
seems like it will affect
from all aspects of health
for the the individual's life and so
that just
in addition to everything else that has
been discussed obviously around health
disparity it seems like sleep is a huge
part of that which i don't hear talked
about as much and maybe that's just the
circles that i am but even in public
discourse it doesn't seem like that's
often brought to the forefront but it
sounds like hopefully there are pushes
to make sure
that becomes a better part of
understanding
yes like i said the academy of sleep
medicine is working on it yeah but it
within the general
medical field maybe it's
we are not getting enough attention on
it it's more recent the academy is
pushing the whole area of the disparity
in the distribution so
first of all in some of the
groups there's such lower socioeconomic
groups
people may not recognize that there is a
problem with sleep and maybe physicians
or
care providers in those places i don't
recognize it enough to encourage the
people to
go but then part of the increase the
level of awareness
in
primary care physicians so they will
recognize this and treat it because some
people are
very far away from any center any sleep
establish the disorder centers but the
thing is to get primary care physicians
to recognize their importance and to
address it because there are many many
things that primary care providers can
do to help right
i'm curious if you ever see any
resistance to that because you talked
about some of the patients that are
resistant to it and don't realize
there's an issue until
you until they've tried to prove you
wrong and they've seen it does that ever
happen with the primary physicians in
certain communities or even in the
community because i'm thinking also
about stigma whether there's stigmas
that are still coming into play as well
i know i asked several questions at once
but yeah no but it's probably more
difficult to with their primary care
physicians because it's i mean for as
long as we've done this in the community
in which i am now there are still some
primary care physicians who almost never
refer a patient
so
and and the knowledge is there you do
educational programs and they attend
these things but maybe like everything
else yeah which
because obviously a physician even when
they've had patients who
have been treated some it look like for
some reason some are still not converged
they still wouldn't
send patients so in a sense it's easier
to convert if you so to speak the
patient who has had a possible
experience than the physician who does
not recognize this no yeah
that's a really good point so people who
are able to just share that in their
communities as well
yeah have you seen that happen in some
ways or in some places either here or in
ghana
have you seen the those who have
actually gone through the experience as
as patients have you seen them have
impact in communities either in the
states or in ghana yes they have
actually when i started here in grand
rapids where one of my colleagues
used to say there is a feminine
prominent physician whose friends were
thinking he was leaving medicine by
going to
sleep
but then he always would encourage he
said uh
our best promoters for their sleep leg
are the patients so you treat the
patient well and i agree we do have a
lot of patients who tell their family
members and friends and colleagues to
come in
and the physicians sometimes become
secondary
they will get a good treatment and they
will tell the physician that well this
is what i realized i have
my cousin needs to go to
so can you refer my cousin to that
so sometimes there is the patient who
drives it yeah so the patients
drive this
in a lot of ways
not so much in ghana and i've started a
relationship with
nigeria i recently learned you can leave
your country and forget the culture
in that culture you don't talk about
your health problems
so then i've seen patients and actually
this last video somebody actually told
me i'm not going to let anyone know
that i'm patient even when they've had a
positive response i'm not going to share
that information with anyone else
so
yes patients
drive
the growth of the clinic here but in a
different culture
that that doesn't work so yeah we want
to work through
the
the primary physicians like we said
again the
role of authority in that context so
it's going to be more important in that
context to convince the physicians to
send patients whereas here the patients
can repair themselves or convince their
doctors to send it
now so it seems a lot just being aware
of just the culture within like you said
it's operating and the system's in place
yeah yeah
very much so
and and obviously when it comes to sleep
they are various sleep disorders i think
you had a question when
does one treat it on their own and when
do you seek
health from a professional
a lot of people with insomnia would try
and manage on their own but
and there's habits and there are
behavioral things you can do to improve
things we talk about their sleep hygiene
and they are more specific things but if
you've done all of these the usual
things you know and they are not working
it's important then to seek professional
health because of the consequences of
untreated insomnia
or
excessive sleepiness
sleep apnea and some of the conditions
that cause excessive sleepiness can be
dangerous because people can get to the
point of falling asleep driving which
puts the person at risk and puts others
on the road at risk as well
so that's an insomnia thing if it's not
improving you should avoid taking
sleeping pills on a long term basis a
sleeping pill may have a place in
managing short-term insomnia problems
but if you are taking whatever you are
taking if you see the dose going up the
dose keeps climbing and the
effectiveness is decreasing that may be
one indication to see
someone
for those who
have problems with snoring
and begin to develop daytime sleeping
they're snoring itself may not
necessarily mean you have a
sleep apnea or major sleep problem but
if there is disruption of your sleep you
don't feel as refreshed when you wake up
in the morning or you are beginning to
have some daytime sleepiness
or in terms of the sleep apnea if
whoever is
sleeping with you or who anyone who has
observed you sleeping comments that it
looks like your breathing gets
interrupted at night
then you want to yeah professional help
for that because that's when you need a
sleep study to clarify what is going on
again it's because of the consequences
risk of getting
a stroke is higher risk of getting a
heart attack is higher
the cognitive
impairment
can come on slowly but it can be
significant
again this is one of those things that
people will recover and go back to work
we are
we relate this to faith as well so then
the example of a pastor comes to mind
who has sleep apnea and didn't recognize
it
things were not prominent
but it was after he got treated that he
said so this is why i was getting to the
point i was having difficulty preparing
my sermons i mean saturday i work on it
and then i'm standing the pulpit and my
things were not clicking and i thought
it's a spiritual thing i'm not praying
enough and think no his sleep apnea was
not treated so his brain was not
functioning i don't know
yeah so when things are not improving
that you've tried on your own then it's
time to see a professional just now
what's going on those are really helpful
really helpful tips as well i'm sure
again that people this is gonna these
are things that people are gonna be
thinking like you said someone who said
i wish i had known this ten years
earlier and those types of things so i
appreciate you sharing those
i'm also curious though because you
talked about how sleep affects overall
health and how it affects mental health
and then if people have a higher
prevalence for depression or anxiety
because of sleep disturbances or the
other way around how do you advise
people
what to tackle first
so i mean if they're noticing that
they're having some challenges with
anxiety but also having challenges with
sleep like where should people go
to try and
address that are there parts they should
try and do on their own do they have to
go because there's also a challenge of
well how many different providers they
have to go to
to deal with the intersections yeah
yeah i think it's as a general rule it's
always good to start with your primary
care provider
and whether it's anxiety or
the sleep thing
anxiety can be so disabling and anxiety
and the depression and i would say that
it's it will make sense to approach the
anxiety or depression
initially
from the standpoint of both counseling
kinds of treatment
as well as medication cancer treatment
you would expect that and i think most
the primary provider who
addresses the depression and anxiety if
they are using counseling or their
psychologists
will give input that will probably
impact positively on the sleep as well
but when it comes to medication
management
many i was going to say most but that's
in the past things have changed but
still
many antidepressant medications and
medications for anxiety have an effect
on promoting sleep as well
so that single agent can address both
the depression
and the sleep so that is a place to
start
better that depression and anxiety are
improving and the sleep is still not
improving enough then you may consider
going to a sleep clinic
but if the major problem is something
like snoring or the sleep is so extreme
that somebody cannot function during the
day and
a lot of patients will be able to
identify which is
more prominent and the sleep is more
disabling it's more significant
it may not be critical of where you
start from most sleep clinic clinicians
are aware of the depression and anxiety
component of things so
when you see them and they say well this
is not so much they sleep it's more the
anxiety and depression
there's an
interesting thing here the stigma about
mental illness is decreasing but it's
still there
and there are many people who prefer to
go to the sleep clinic first
not because that's the most part but
that's more acceptable a sleep
problem is it's funny the way a sleep
problem is a medical biological problem
but it's mental illness problem is
non-medical it's it's your mind it's
doing something and it's that's
not as acceptable to most people
and
again in the faith community there's
been
again it's proving
that if you have a mental health problem
then it's a lack of faith
or it's your poor decision making or
it's your poor choices that's what is
causing it
that may not necessarily be so but as i
was thinking about this
it doesn't mean
that it's your fault although you may
have something to do with it in the same
way that
somebody's eating habits in their
lifestyle
may promote their risk of developing
diabetes and two diabetes
so somebody's poor choices and prohibits
may lead to a sleep problem or a mental
health problem
but on the other hand there can be
somebody who develops type 1 but
diabetes the child who develops
childhood diabetes may have done all the
right things there are some things we
inherit
so we should look at both the same way
you can develop diabetes even when
you've done all the right things
but you can develop diabetes because you
some that's on the wrong thing
so in the mental health arena there's no
reason we should look at it any
differently
you can develop a sleep problem when
you've done all the right things
but you can also develop a sleep problem
because you haven't done the right thing
so it's important to pay attention to
that because i think we run the risks
sometimes of excusing people because we
want to look at the biological and it
has nothing to do with what you did it's
it's all just biological it's the
holistic idea of things and again you
will ask me this you asking
the whole thing about where does faith
come comes in
god made us one i mean you have we have
the physical
component of ourselves our emotional
components our spiritual component and
we like to separate the different parts
of it it should be all one whole thing
and in all of these areas
it may be predetermined or nothing we
did wrong but in some other areas or in
all of the areas it may be something we
need to do right
because i think sometimes we excuse
people no you didn't do anything wrong
well maybe wrong is not the right term
but no there's some you have some
responsibility there are some things you
probably didn't do as well and some
things you can improve to change things
so so i shouldn't go on then i'll become
like i'm preaching yeah
well that was so well said i mean just
all the different components that you
you brought in together um especially
about the holistic approach to these
things so i think it's it's not
easy but important for us to continue to
to wrestle through and of course even as
you're talking i'm seeing where some of
my own
influences and thinking came from
because you could be hosting this
podcast with those themes and just all
the things
incorporated so it's a good um reminder
to me also of the example that you've
set in your profession how that is
something that i've been able to
also carry out from you without even
realizing how much of that actually
might have originated
with you or those it influenced you as
well so
i mean i think it's very well said just
all the different components that we
have to think about versus
just trying to put things in one box or
another because they're all interplaying
i mean even as you were talking the
people were saying well this is because
of your own poor decision making that
you have this health ailment or the
sleep issue but then you also said that
the sleep can lead to poor decision
making so it seems like those two
can't be divorced and it's really
important to help people have you seen
as a closing question have you seen us
as a society get better about moving
towards what you just stated for that
holistic approach or
are there i mean clearly there's still
ways we need to grow in that but have
you seen it shifting or are we still far
from where we need to be yes no i think
there's a definite shift okay and and
you are an example of that okay so
when we're doing this duke when we
started doing faith and health
it was on the side it wasn't part of the
program and
and there was a lot of resistance to
that i mean it's
you know
30 years ago i mean 40 years ago
no university would be
hosting this no university wants its
name attached to what we are doing now
so it's it's moved it's moved a lot and
it's good to to see that yeah so
it's i mean we still have ways to go and
there are still areas to develop but you
know as i look at you i say where your
influences come from well it's it's it's
but as i'm looking at you doing this i
feel like well you are doing so much
greater work than i ever did and i don't
see myself and
doing a whole lot so so we are very
thankful no but we've made progress and
i think we'll continue to make progress
and it's more open and it's more the
forum the things you've done with the
town hall meetings again these were done
on a small scale basis so we are way
ahead of where we were uh
20
30 years ago even 10 years ago so it's
it's we are making progress but we
shouldn't just stop now
say where we've achieved our goal as
paul says we keep striving to for the
goal and we are not there yet and
we
so long as we live we need to keep
striving to reach
higher levels
i'm grateful to be able to play a part
in that as well and to carry the legacy
on and it's helpful just to have that
context reminder to to know even just
what we're doing now and how much
growth we've had as a society and as
universities to be able to have those
types of intersecting conversations and
really think about ourselves as whole
people so
so i think i hope some of the things
i've said will be helpful to some people
and
yeah
so but if it's only one person i said
it's i mean i in a sense i went to my
mental health for one or two people i
went to sleep medicine for one person so
yeah if one person benefits from this i
suppose it's good to try yeah and i know
that many many have and i think that
will continue as well so
thank you so much for joining the addie
hour your namesake podcast in a sense
so it's i'm grateful and i know this is
definitely going to bless a lot of
people um
something that's it's been gratifying
for me and i always learn more every
time i talk through these things with
you as surprising as that may seem to
some so thank you
great having you on the addie hour and i
hope that you all enjoyed this episode
and share it widely cause i think
there's so many important things here
that people will benefit from as well
until next time
[Music]
you